ce journal mais pour commencer
l'actualité c'est évidemment ce concert
XXL ce soir au château de Chambord après
Sting l'an dernier c'est donc imagine
dragons qui était attendu dans ce cadre
majestueux face au groupe américain 30
000 fans qui ont acheté leur billet il y
a déjà plusieurs mois à 1h15 maintenant
du concert la température grimpe encore
un peu plus sur le fer à cheval où l'on
retrouve les la Turquie
oui c'est déjà
libellule tous les groupes se préparent
avant d'entrer sur scène nous avons
rencontré tellement l'un des trois
groupes en première partie d'Imagine
dragons ils sont tout ranjo et
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour eux
bah c'est assez incroyable un peu
vertigineux même au départ quand on a
appris ça c'était genre waouh c'est quoi
cette nouvelle de dingue surtout dans un
contexte aussi incroyable que Chambord
en tout cas on a une de l'énergie à
revendre à fond et puis on a trop hâte
quoi ils ont hâte et ce ne sont pas les
seuls dans le public tout le monde
trépigne t'impatience beaucoup se sont
levés tôt et ont fait des kilomètres
pour voir l'un des groupes de pop rock
les plus connus du monde on est arrivé
premier dans la queue on s'est caché du
soleil comme on pouvait et du coup bah
ça valait le coup parce que on est tout
devant on est super fans
et puis c'était à Chambord donc c'est
pas loin de chez moi donc c'était plutôt
pas mal et le cadre et magnifique
incroyable on peut pas rêver mieux quoi
avec le château c'est incroyable quoi
11 ans on va depuis leur première album
donc là c'était vraiment l'occasion en
or honnêtement donc on est magique comme
ça on les a vu il y a qu'un jour à Paris
on a eu la chance et puis là voilà on
refait pareil hein de nouveau latente
sous le soleil ça fait tout le champ du
truc mais bon c'est un peu dur imagine
dragons ça c'est maintenant dans à peine
quelques heures plus de 30000 personnes
sont attendues pour cette deuxième
édition du Chambord live festival